hey how's it going bros my name is Peter
pie and welcome to three free games of
boots oh my god we have the best games
ever for you bros today we're gonna
start off with game by robert yang okay
I don't know what's gonna happen
all I know is I can do this by moving my
mouse
why am I doing this is it getting bigger
oh my
yes Oh what happened what happened is
everyone okay
can I change gear okay I can know what
the [ __ ] it is Kay stop cruising down
the street in math 6 go flap in the
picture all right
we're in second gear baby calm down calm
down calm down baby oh now I see
yes yes wonderful
aah third gear third gear third yes dad
I came too fast I came to that as this
is the greatest game of all town we
found it finally breast a game that I
generated 11 out of 10 that's quite
impressive
I can't believe it after all these games
here [ __ ] for the for you those
who you who are Americans or too young
to drive this is pretty much exactly how
it works
how [ __ ] fast can they go in the
first year ah yes I think we did it yes
here's three baby Wow filling it oh my
god [ __ ] hell this [ __ ] what are
you what are you doing
yes yes ah
Oh God get for baby oh oh dear five get
ready
nope oh yeah [ __ ] sex baby next
game is super smash brothers version 1.1
I'm player 2 then alright I can choose
between
mayro sanic shulk spanish fix magma what
[Music]
[ __ ]
final game is a good husband a lot of
you brother jested this game so I assume
that it's like the greatest thing that
ever came to happen
hey BR I come home
six months ago what does that mean you
are living you don't need to see your
friends anymore where's my waist my
darling there she is are you doing baby
I'm watching that [ __ ] watching
origins in your black
I got - two points for blocking the TV
great do I get points for doing like
yeah I get points for doing the dishes
cuz I'm a good husband [ __ ]
that is my kidney and it looks a bit
burnt but I bet she will love it honey
honey I cooked you some kidney so I
still have minus 2 points ask her about
the bill honey take care of that bill
honey honey honey it's your bill you
bought you bought a trench coat I don't
know what are you what did that ails to
be honest and just imagine that's what
girls bad i guess i'll i guess i'll go
in over my lawn now
my life is empty food ammo good husband
that was fun hundred points
put the seat up - ten white the power
shut up I'm tired of it three months ago
oh she's letting a ginger kid [ __ ] oh
my god this is all too much I'm gonna
360 noscope my [ __ ] wife what do you
think you're doing with that watch this
I'll montage you [ __ ] I'm beginning
I'll shoot the TV what
no I shut the tape I shut the TV no
alright friends if you enjoyed this
episode go ahead and hit that like
button share with all your friends leave
a comment post it on Facebook Twitter
Pinterest your website your blog put a
flyer out and be those things that you
tear off with my youtube channel on it
adopt a kid and train him to subscribe
to me and that's all you have to do
thank you so much for watching click to
watch another one and I'll see you both
in the next one
stay awesome it sexist best place that
will be boobs
I know it my Milken thank you very much
that would be a shoulder good job way to
spot the shoulder hey what can it's a
gimme I'm a shoulder man